[Musik]
ernüchterung bei der svp zürich der
wichtigsten sektion der partei der
nationale wähleranteil bricht um fast
vier prozent ein
12 nationalratssitze sind weg damit ist
die svp die große verliererin der
eidgenössischen wahlen 2009 10
toni bortoluzzi ist vizepräsident der
svp zürich für ihn war schon vor der
wahlschlappe klar die volkspartei muss
grundlegende probleme lösen wenn sie
zurück will auf die siegerstraße so
schön dreifach verwalter das land der
politik nicht und das ist ein leidiges
resultat wird aus bestätigen albert
rösti der präsident der svp schweiz
bedauert das ergebnis betonte aber seine
partei bleibe klar stärkste kraft
zurücktreten will er nicht die jungs
glauben kaum von der frau klären oder
aber da was man natürlich über bürger
und präsident vertreibt wo so viel weil
total verloren hat europa sei das
braucht will ich einfach grundsätzlich
erneuerung der parteistruktur ein weiter
so sei ausgeschlossen
die svp zürich müsse national wieder
mehr einfluss nehmen und helfen die
dringend nötigen korrekturen in die wege
zu leiten
im konferenzraum geht's mal kommt die
verschiebungen die wirklich verlieren
die grünen und grünliberalen im detail
es deshalb hebelt meter vierte partie
verliert wird aber nun sitzt die krise
der svp ist bereits im frühling
offensichtlich erfolgsverwöhnte partei
schweiz schon längeren kantonalwahlen
aber das ergebnis der zürcher sektion
ist ein desaster
konrad lang hat der zürcher
kantonalpräsident macht indes keine
anstalten seinen stuhl zu räumen
aber im moment bin ich parteipräsident
und wieder verantwortlich dass die
partei wieder gehört wird und die option
jetzt auf der bettelei ratlos wie granit
alt
doch es kommt anders die ganze zürcher
parteileitung offenbar auf druck von
christoph buch
[Musik]
rund zwei monate später trifft sich die
zürcher svp hüntwangen zur
delegiertenversammlung ab traktandum die
verabschiedung der nationalratsliste
blocher hat einen neuen vize präsidentin
installiert und nationalrat toni
bortoluzzi seinen langjährigen
wegbegleiter und vertrauten
[Musik]
der zuvor völlig unbekannte public war
ist nun präsident und schießt in seiner
antrittsrede scharf gegen seinen
vorgänger wo sie besteht ich wir grünen
fordern zwanziger strukturen und alles
andere als bürger von comedy frau
zürcher svp ist nun mal sind ganz der
papa unterwegs haben chefs damen und
herren mit eröffneten sich ihm wieder
lauter werden
lang hat sogar von der nationalratsliste
verschwinden findet blocher
schwiegersohn und dem sv ist
dass er die letzte firma nicht nach der
party eine datei
[Musik]
wo sie wohl gefühlt nachdem er zur
platte und intermodal hat eine größe von
sie in der sache hier als chance hatte
der antrag hat keine chance
ob die botschaft ist unmissverständlich
lang hart ist vorbei
als zweite heimat
von hier stammt seine frau es ist sein
zweitwohnsitz
[Musik]
er ist erstaunt und verärgert wie wenig
hinter den kulissen gearbeitet wurde in
den vergangenen vier jahren
die svp habe sich auf dem rekordresultat
von 2015 ausgeruht die nationalen wahlen
im herbst drohen verloren zu gehen
so wie die zürcher kantonalen im
frühling war sollte es wird passieren
und vereinsleben bekomme ich den fuß das
natürlich muss wachsen wenn das ist dass
sie später den shootern oder meine
mannschaft erfolg hat dann versucht man
es mit einer neuen trainer
es ist der zweitwärmste seit messbeginn
die ganze schweiz redet über den
klimawandel
die linksgrünen parteien reiben sich die
hände von der nationalen svp kommt dazu
nichts
[Musik]
sicher mit ihrer wärme der schotte die
svp versucht das klimathema als
irrelevant darzustellen oder
totzuschweigen der volkspartei muss zu
ihrem thema keine antwort arbeit im
zentrum vom in trance vor dem portal ist
aber dann tot
was macht eine und die haben wir zum
teil gerne können also in sachen klima
ist mir völlig unvorbereitet durfte weil
zug oder mit progress abgekürzt zum
klima war darf seitdem suite werden aber
auch weniger als politische antwort
bürger lassen foto thies hauptwohnsitz
in affoltern am albis
mit stufe die gute stube plakatsujets
für den wahlkampf der zürcher svp liegen
vor und auch ist logan ist bekannt frei
und sicher entwickelt von einem kleinen
kreis und produktion blocher die svp
schweiz soll auf die zürcher linie
einschwenken
der unmut über die nationale
parteileitung wächst die svp politisch
nur noch so dahin wo die hunde der
bayern bei der mentalität ag zu kaufen
solche republic stabil public aber nicht
mit mit tower oder dass ich glaube der
unterschied und das max einfach nicht
lieder interesse wenn man hat immer
meter geschafft und du darfst wohnen und
public is wo erhalt der lauf als zu
verlusten führt
wichtig seien klare feindbilder zum
beispiel die eu wagen will er für mich
fällt natürlich steinfurter der
eigentliche täter aber das heißt noch um
wenn man weiss noch nicht nach
vertrauten ich würde ja ja bei dirk
laucke die muss noch die pläne noch
bezeichnet weiter das spiel
ich hoffe mir natürlich weitaus als
demokrat oder und ein wirt aus lützow
ärgern und vor allem mit einer
mobilisierte zum kommune also die
hoffentlich kann ich und den lehrern
orientiere ich mich liege und kampagne
ist so ausgerichtet dass das dass man
versucht das
bad lippspringe als reaktion auf die
klimadebatte hat die zürcher svp den
sogenannten klima teufel erfunden und
lange an einem slogan gefällt das ist
bis jetzt habe bis hoch strichen text
immer gefunden was nicht unbedingt immer
autos dass eine stadt oder und wann
reagiert peters nicht unbedingt
steirische unter technisches know-how
auf und wieder hoffnung
doch nach 2015 machte sich der svp
wahlkampf praktisch von alleine am 15
klassische wahl hat man natürlich vor
dem unglück als terrorakt flüchtling ist
einfach ein aktienrückkauf sich oder für
das papier oder auf fall für für dieses
ergebnis erzielt hat
ein anderer svp klassiker sind die
kriminellen ausländer
unvergessen sind der sogenannte
schäfchen plakat und ähnliches
das mit die kriminellen russland dass
ich das thema mir kurt massenevent
kriminell hughes landet ich meine da
haben wir natürlich habe ich
irgendwelche statistik wenn also bis 100
fuß machen oder ob es müsste aber dass
sie damit als mit
thematisiert wie die ausländer grünen
haben ihr nein zum ewr der beitritt zum
europäischen wirtschaftsraum scheitert
am volks und am ständemehr nachdem ewm 1
war die hierarchie in der svp blocher
und seine thüringer flügel gaben den ton
an
sie gehörte über 20 jahre lang zum
engsten führungszirkel um blocher und
war entsprechend einflussreich er sei
eine zentrale figur gewesen sagen svp
inside wenn sie irgendwelche sachen
wichtige entscheide gehabt da wird er
christoph blocher immer gesagt toni
bortoluzzi der wille mit am tisch schade
hatten gute buch ist das ist ja das weiß
ich nicht
rasche und lernt dank der große bruch
naja fast spielend politischem gespür
dafür blüht sie spüre die ehre für
kambodscha oder er ist gelernter
schreiner und wurde deshalb von
außenstehenden oft unterschätzt
intern war das nie so ergab das dossier
fest wurde respektiert und gefürchtet
hinterzimmer treffen in einem zürcher
landgasthof mit ehemaligen und aktuellen
svp grüßen
hier werden fäden gezogen die politische
karriere von hans tochter so gepusht
werden
ein wiederkehrendes thema der runde
der schleichende bedeutungsverlust in
die zürcher svp in der nationalen partei
seit blochers abwahl aus dem bundesrat
erleben musste das soll sich ändern
ich hoffe dass ein troll gestiegen die
der schweizerische partei unterschrieb
für übernahmen des studentischen also
das heißt das dass man zum beispiel in
zürcher svp präsident nationale die
haare genau genau das ist für mich das
wichtigste aus wonach er wieder mit
lupin aus der präsident ist unter den
einer wohl der in der parteileitung
bedeutung hat das bild an sich nicht so
aber dass es zu sehen wo schweizerischer
ebene wie das mehrgewicht überkommen als
7 kann er auch der erste sitzung der
kantonalen parteileitung nach der
sommerpause
[Musik]
es geht nur noch um administrative
strategischen entscheidungen sind
gefallen die plakatsujets wurden
inzwischen finalisiert die eu sterne der
karte fehlen aber weiterhin man muss
natürlich parat sie werden sich
irgendwas thema ergeht aktuellen
politisch wieder auf
auch die korrektur nötig sind aber
sorgsam zimmerwand meldung
dann lanciert die svp schweiz das
sogenannte wurde plakat und löst
weiterem entsetzen aus nicht nur bei
politischen gegnern sondern auch in den
eigenen reihen
nein
ein bisschen stolz hier muss sagen mit 2
aber das ist natürlich ein morgen jetzt
rum marke
bortoluzzi und ein svp kollege ein
vormaliger malermeister wollen rund um
erfolgten plakate aufstellen
das ist praktisch wie zum toaster stoff
kommt unschuldig wir sind für den kanton
zürich zuständig also kommt noch die gkk
chinesischer musik und wie ist das bei
ihnen auch deshalb für plakat
wie ist das bei ihnen auch ein plakat
bei mir ja bei mir ist das sehr gut acht
bin ich natürlich weiß dass man
rechtlich muss provozieren weil wir das
thema wird auf der auf der agenda
bringen
um simon die stege glaube wir sind am
stock
[Musik]
nicht unbedingt
die plakatständer lagen in einem
schuppen am waldrand zeit für eine
einführung in die kühl kalkulierte
provokation slogan der svp zuerst eine
bombe platzen lassen dann ein thema auf
die politische agenda trinken wenn du
provokationen intensiv wie klingt
eigentlich schön verschreckt
der muss auch richtig die tatsachen und
posters gold das hat ja inhalt sich
nicht nur der us vogue wo man im moment
blog aktiv war nimmt zu und das hat ihn
haut und hat hintergrund und das muss
man erklären und dann wird die
provokation sofort relativiert
primäres ziel dieses wahlkampfes sei
nicht neue wähler zu gewinnen sondern
die eigenen zu mobilisieren
das mobilisiere erfolg natürlich unter
anderem mit der provokation oder das
gemerkt es geht um die server und und
gespürt werden
er stand unter druck mit einer
politischen haltung und das glaube ich
der aktuelle die mobilisierung sei bei
diesen wahlen entscheidend für die svp
in die analyse der zürcher kantonalen
zeigte genau das war nicht gelungen und
hatte zu herben verlusten geführt
[Musik]
es macht doch so ansteigen
bortoluzzi zh packard chef der zürcher
svp das heißt er muss kontrollieren ob
flächendeckend plakatiert wurde mit
plakaten gegen jemand keine wahlen sagt
er aber man könne sie verlieren wenn zu
wenig plakate stünden ende gelände
zimmer natürlich auch autogramme
wenn ich mich eine dusche
[Musik]
also hab ich aus dem nichts
und oscar
[Musik]
er nimmt sich mehrere tage zeit und
verträumt und quer durch die haut und
zürich um sich einen überblick über die
blockade situation zu verschaffen
jetzt zum beispiel da habe ich einfach
nix aber dann werde ich auch so
was ist los mit toyoda des enkels
mitteilen
da
ragen aus dem boden aber bis auf zwei
svp
das ist so dass das zum ausdruck bringen
die wand das mobilisiert die eigene zeit
für eine grundsätzliche lagebeurteilung
im restaurant sonne in dielsdorf auch
vor dass auch sie sind hof zum
wahlplakate müssen möglichst einfach
sein aber die welt ist kompliziert nicht
wahr große kommt so ist es nicht so
kompliziert wird dann zum teil
wirkungsstätte ich habe inzwischen in
rom gedreht wird eingestellt und das
jahr zählt der vierte hat es ist detail
völlig komplex oder ob es wesentlich
wohler stimmbürger muss darüber befinden
richtig wo es wichtig dass ich nie also
so kompliziert und der wahlkampf ist auf
der zielgeraden
die svp zürich trifft sich auf dem
münsterhof zu einem sogenannten
mobilisierungs anlass die prognosen
sagen der partei verluste voraus ein
offizielles ziel ist es diese möglichst
klein zu halten
die offizielle devise lautet optimismus
verbreiten
allenthalben und in allen farben
thomas hasler an diesem schönen job oder
frau kann man auch machen wenn das so
gut behauptet serie geschlagen geben
auch konrad lang hart der gewesene
kantonalpräsident ist gekommen man
würdigt sich keines blickes lang hat
steht zwar weiter auf der
nationalratsliste der svp aber seine
politische karriere dürfte vorbei sein
und seine beginnt vielleicht ist wichtig
[Musik]
es ist ein folklore anlass für
gleichgesinnte aber auch eine
möglichkeit im kleinen kreis wir nach
den wahlen vor zu spüren
das ziel ist klar die zürcher wollen
wieder das sagen haben in der svp und
das was noch kommt
die show ist vorbei und die strategie
ist schon vor dem wahltag definiert in
allen wichtigen kommissionen sollen
künftig wieder zürcher svp in der 17
in allen wichtigen dossiers sollen ziel
den ton angeben
so dominiert man eine partei so geht
politik
[Musik]